today's topic preaches favorite channel
Jubilee even during this quarantine they
still manage to produce quality content
so let's take a look hi my name is
Carlos dear Donny if you had the
opportunity to date someone from another
country which country would be from I'd
have to go with London more so because
I'm a big Harry Potter fan so if she has
a cool British accent that would be kind
of nice I bet you this guy's fantasies
is to be like in bed jet girls like you
ready to do this and he's like yeah and
then she's like when Guardian Leviosa
and his erection just pops out only
smell I know from Harry Potter
because I never watched it but sometimes
I would go to the theaters and then I
would see a bunch of nerds robes I'm
like Harry Potter's coming out that's
the only time here we go
[Music]
hi ladies how we doing first just it
looks like natural the second ones like
I'm here look at me right I got my
wisdom teeth out and I was a square for
a good two weeks
oh my wait so this isn't like a snapchat
filter or anything know that that's my
actual face conversation Casanova what's
on your face my face kinda looks like
somebody I know he looks like a friend
of mine who's a comedian named Nick
Reynolds great comedian by the way if
you guys can't look him up he said he's
very funny
Nicholas Reynolds him somewhat uh yeah
this looks like a tired version of the
other day mm-hmm yeah and you like rock
and roll yeah I do like rock music any
any time any day what I'm showering I'm
just like I just sounded like a good BJ
that's what a good BJ sounds like a
wonderfully committed
[Music]
and I know there's a bunch of [ __ ] in
this but okay when someone goes down on
you and they soundin rightful
association so you could shoot oh yeah I
used to I guarantee you if she put that
profile up on tenders the whole bunch of
guys like so you're good with rifles huh
you like shooting other people's weapons
you yeah you want to pull the trigger on
something else oh boy here we go
let's pull trigger on this date first do
another one girl you like hard hold long
things that shoot projectiles huh huh
good I want you to pick me guys we don't
know how YouTube's gonna react to these
videos they D monetizing monetizing
things it's been super confusing for me
so if you want to ensure that this video
does well please hit the like button it
helps the satellite comment help with
all that algorithm stuff and yeah we
also have a peach run you can check out
so if you want to see more of us we have
a podcast there it has a very deep vibe
and maybe an emotional vibe oh is this
the one in the mirror this is here's the
thing she was both talked about like
deep lies blah blah blah then he heard
her accent he went okay now I'm
interested
you found a ship there he's like okay
deep yeah mirror anyway very nice clean
okay you have a very nice you started
off well clean were you going from there
I was hoping to say forehead because the
girls love being complimented on their
fine I think he's gonna say skin I hope
he says Jim yeah he's gonna say skin hey
thanks listen I know you're gonna watch
this video bro and I just want to know
as a Jubilee employee this is not hate
this is constructive criticism okay I
don't want you to make another video
talking about how you were yeah how are
you
not too great struggling yeah I get it
Carlos you have to eliminate five girls
make a decision now hi everyone first of
all you guys were all really nice to
talk to if I had the chance to meet all
of y'all I would shut up shut the [ __ ]
up
Fergie it's me setup just set up set up
that what you mean yeah that so blind
date you have to eliminate people do you
want to go on a second date first and
foremost I'd like to say that fountain
big fountain big just go ahead choose so
hard not like you just don't want to
look like the bad guy
you're choosing okay just go first off
millennia I'm so sorry I just don't feel
like we would click showering I'm just
like you don't want that brough you are
missing out on what may possibly be the
most wild experience I mean the first
time that happened I honestly thought my
thing was stuck in a blender oh really
because there's something weird to see a
girl it's just like oh like that girl
with the the grapefruit the grapefruit
technique yes yeah girl yeah she's going
in like but I was about to say a pool
filter sounds like it's crazy
oh sorry Tanisha next person that I'll
be eliminating is Shivani
[Music]
you got a bullet there Bubba yeah why
why are you breaking up with me
she's Portuguese too huh that's too bad
could have been hilarious if she woke up
one morning hey we're going to make sure
that's the word wants to make love
morning yes because your name is if
Carlos say I like it I want you to make
love in you're happy because my half is
a bed is so cold do you like music we
listen to heck hurts to give that's
pretty good every single one of those
girls was so so lovely was I expecting
that if I picked someone who would just
be the one who's closest to me like I'm
not going to pick someone from India
during a virus lockdown you know as if
we're gonna do a follow-up not gonna do
Japan no no you like to me it's kind of
stupid lessons the country I know I'm
gonna visit soon but anyways I'm from
Rio from Canada all the way across the
sea whose ammonia I don't know I pick
one Brazil maybe I got I got Harry
Potter go I think you like the Asian
persuasion that trap suit new contender
has appeared because he saw local eggs I
know we might be able to smack layer
number two right when you get enough
points so you can finally unlock that
lock characters enjoy I love everything
yeah wiping with that's me no no I love
life I love positivity I love cupcakes I
love lemonade and I just love just
putting good things out there and I'm a
Care Bear and just I shoot hearts out of
my heart and oh my god
are you close I want to suck your I hate
it
that's too much I just think that other
girls gave me more energetic answers so
I'm gonna have to eliminate lil I'm so
sorry
Oh Harry Potter girls gone that's kids
now he already has a side Miss America
round three is gonna be the kitchen tour
I'm gonna do a little P Diddy type
welcome to my crib we got two fridges
and on saying why are your bananas moldy
wow they're not moldy yeah they're super
ripe but they're not moldy yeah this is
that Americans have an obsession with
yellow looking yellow yellow bananas
yeah that's how you know you've lived in
a privileged place yeah but they're not
like the yellow yellow bananas or not
done they're not don't outright those
are the been ads I went to school with
you taking this out of my childhood my
dude yeah but you know those bananas the
tastiest sauces I honestly do like it
with a little bit more yellow because I
don't like it when it's too too soft
personally but I didn't think they were
moldy if your banana black black damn
banana bread you know I mean yeah ask
you stick to do something buddy
moldy no moldy oh man Wow did you say
that's not a banana no give back your
hispanic card what kind of Latino
American has never heard of Twenties
what rock do you live under do you know
how many Hispanic and he called them
bananas moldy doesn't know what a
plantain is so this is the people are
doing this is there anything you'd
recommend that I learn how to cook I
would go for a classic feijoada classic
fish wonderful waddler because it when
you're busted it's the official other we
wants to see that's it beans are so good
for you you know fish the Kumar would
notice you
epical it never from home never for xun
hey fellows Tabu people's father mmm mmm
which is like the Brazilian beans which
are the best in the world
I'm sorry to stay with you I love Brazil
for a lot of different reasons medicine
are lighter so the food isn't like top
pop no but job y'all don't people when I
love you come here but let's slop okay
you're you're not you're not eating the
top ranked but you can love your food I
respect it like your shirt off Korea is
nice but everybody barbecues the most
Canadian thing you can find in a fridge
that is good that is Canadian is you
know what's funny
Canada is known for prisoners choice
maple syrup we don't have a prison in we
have a prime minister and a queen the
first person I'm going to eliminate is
theis holy cxeh Toby the lack of sushi I
feel like we wouldn't be able to enjoy
some seafood itself I hope I give me the
sushi one day the next girl in M&A
I feel like we just didn't get along as
well
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna have to go with Jennings again
so sir told you black girls you're not
gonna make it no way the girl from
whatever the places near do buyer
Bahrain she's gonna get lemonade next
I gotta go with Natalie on this one I
love he doesn't have the grown taste
suppose after the sister palette this is
not reflective of Mike takes no I'm all
for it I would not have lived Nita
longer than that but I could tell he
wasn't feeling it so let's say I go to
Canada right and we meet up would be
your ideal you don't know that's it
if you love that said I love that said
no that's it look that's it yeah like
that's a red or white wine white maybe a
really nice breakfast that back you lies
you which is the National Park we could
go to the National Museum and just spend
the whole day looking she's definitely
giving like sometimes but like I liked
like simply watch a projector so we can
watch a movie like it reject Victor my
like backyard I like the wall of the
house make some homemade pizza bulik
works
I hate her like scary I actually do like
horror panic answers okay oh my god so
what we should do
okay so like I got a project that we got
yeah but to protect it on my wall like
oh wait wait a minute no my wall is
insane
I got another wall particular on the
other wall alright cool and then we say
that you like alright I don't like or
you like art so from no Brian's okay
okay I'll do it I'll do it like oh this
is she she's doing the most but here's
the thing right I think he might have
she might have messed up rods right
there so what she's doing too much I
think he's gonna be yeah she messed it
up
the first person I will eliminate is and
this is only because the ideal date
didn't speak to me as much as the other
ones is Priscilla I'm sorry I'm just not
down for a museum date I'm gonna
eliminate Julia for you just were too
annoying you had it in the bag sister
and then you're just like this and I
just like love Care Bears cuz I got
hearts poured out of my heart so I'm
just like God you like our no okay it's
not a problem just you doing too much yo
babe what do you want to eat I don't
like what do you want to eat I think yo
calm down can you imagine this girl on
speed no yeah I feel like just time
would stop like she would just break the
system she took this feed out of us be
baiting and yeah excuse me sorry Lauren
excuse me so much fun Thank You Jubilee
for having me fun fact I like girls too
so if any of the girls involved you're
like calling me Academy as far as like
your future long-term goals like where
do you see yourself in ten years what do
you want to accomplish
I realize especially like oneexchange
how much I value you in connection and
like relationship building and so I
definitely wouldn't do something where
I'm able to combine those passions what
do you aspire to be in the future I am
actually currently in my dream job so
I'm a video producer and I basically do
very similar things to what we're doing
right now probably take me somewhere to
Hollywood and that's right where you are
so
yeah she slide it in I know who I want
I've been leaning towards one person but
Gwen I would like to go on a date with
you let's do such a great guy we're so
lucky to have one she's hilarious that
was annoying me just the word love I
love you girl I love you I love you I
love you love you love you love you you
don't know them sound like a good song I
know love you love you look I know I got
I hit the note I'm like well you still
talking to the court she will not going
up on a girl I don't get it why would
you just pick the person that's closer
to you that's my thing this is panic
dude that don't know plantain we got a
girl yeah it's great
moldy bananas it's not more like the
fact that he got it we're bananas and
not like things I get that like they
look big did look the same right on
camera and stop that but moldy so you're
really upset about the plantains moldy
some people just don't know if you guys
are nowhere with plantains are I suggest
you google them because they are one of
the best best food items you can have on
a plate though that's all I'm gonna say
about bananas that's it for today's
video tell us what you guys thought
about some of the choices what do you
guys think about moldy bananas people
want to hear your thoughts leave a
comment
you don't leave plantain in the fridge
that's a problem she was I guess
[Music]
it has a very deep vibe and maybe an
emotional vibe
oh is this the one in the mirror this is
oh wow I love your accent mirror is a
hard word for people to say yeah mirror
even here in Quebec where people speak
French so that mirror like they're half
yeah yeah yeah Mirror Mirror we're
trying to explain to them how to say
this very different I gotta agree I am
most effective when I see mirror in a
British accent yeah mirror sounds better
you actually know what the person near
yeah you just saw it's a confused cat
Nia
Mirror Mirror Sameera